leaving the teams is a dramatic event
as traumatic which you have proved look
at this look at the I mean the the
infrastructure that's surrounding you at
this point it's a you have to do
something to account for that trauma and
I always used to think that I was immune
to you know you know the leaving leaving
the teams and I was never going to you
know fill it with anything else and you
know I'd never gotten any tattoos I'd
never you know I didn't get into
triathlons or anything like that I just
had this huge blind spot creeping up on
me that I didn't even know about once
this thing found me I was Hostage to it
like there wasn't anything I mean it was
it dominated my life you know I don't I
try to really you know curtail the
amount of time that I put into it I only
work in the morning I'd work in the
evening you know after the kids were in
bed
um but what I found was that I would
leave off uh writing or researching and
then throughout the day this thing would
just be on a loop in my head and I
couldn't break away